Outlander and there was all this buzz I
mean obviously it's coming from a
successful book series but did you have
any idea the show was gonna be as big as
it was I was very hopeful you know
because it was a successful book series
and there were pre-existing fans we went
out and did a did an event for fans in
New York City months before the the show
was broadcast and prac I think was a
year before the show was broadcast and I
brought just some concept art and you
know we hadn't cast a lot of it yet and
it was just very rough but we packed
that house and those those people that
came to that event were passionate and
thrilled and excited and I was it was
amazing because there was no show yet
there were just the books and but the
fans turned out so it gave me hope right
from the beginning that if we did this
right it could be a phenomena because
there was there were literally millions
of people who loved these books and if
we did the book adaptation right they
would come to the show and that's what
that's what happened the show would be
nothing without the chemistry between
your two leads I mean that that's so key
talk a little bit about when you knew
you had the right people and sort of
talk about that casting process because
it must have been so daunting going in
trying to figure out you know the two
right people yeah it was tricky you know
at the beginning I said we're gonna cast
Claire first because she'll be the
easiest to find because she's a smart
20th century British woman and there's
lots of them and that'll be something
will find her quickly but Jamie's gonna
be tough how do you find the king of men
this this heroic figure this Scott you
know that knowing that's gonna be the
one that kills us and of course it was
acting exactly the opposite we found Sam
he was the first cast member we just saw
his tape and we went oh my god there he
is it was just like boom and then it was
the great hunt for Claire and we read a
lot of actresses we saw a lot of tape
and it was tricky we it was really
trying to find a very special quality I
I always said that you know I wanted
Claire how to be really smart and you
had to see her thinking and you know she
had to be this really capable
interesting person and she had to marry
up really well with Sam and so we didn't
find her until very late in the game and
she taped her own
her own audition and sent it in and it
was discovered and we put her and Sam
together for a tip for a kid what's
called a chemistry test for you put them
both on a camera and just let him play a
scene together the see how it feels but
we knew we just were like pretty certain
from her tape that she was the one and
then when we saw the chemistry test we
were convinced and once we cast her she
was on a plane to Scotland within a day
and shooting like two days later I mean
we were so close to the beginning of
production it was really starting to
scare everyone though oh my god we have
to cast this role that has to be that's
crazy that you were that close yeah it
was very crazy that's I I can't imagine
also the network must have been on your
back like are you effing kidding me you
know they were you know they were
worried too but the thing when you shoot
when you're casting a pilot the
network's right there with you the
network and the studio and the producers
were all in the throes of it and we're
all struggling to find it so we all have
to agree so it wasn't like we were just
off doing our thing and they would tell
them they were part and parcel the whole
conversation so they knew they were like
oh my god we've got to find somebody
when you it's based on a hugely
obviously so many books how did you
figure out in terms of did you go in to
the network when you were pitching it
and say this is what I'm envisioning for
five years this is what I'm envisioning
for multiple seasons or were you sort of
just like how were those conversations
early on in the original pitch I pretty
much said here's what the pilot story is
and I can I could kind of pitch them the
basic of the pilot because I had that
pretty much in my head and what that was
gonna be and then I gave him a sketch of
the first season generally and I just
said and it's gonna be sort of a book a
book per season and we'll keep that
going and I left them a stack of books
to read which they actually did and then
they picked up the show because they
kind of saw the potential and they could
see how well this would layout into an
ongoing series um talk I know that for
for people that aren't current on the
show what can you tease people about
what's coming up and then what's going
on in the development process in terms
of you know with everything shut down
and whatnot yeah I mean coming up you
know as we go
for word we people who saw this last
season of the fifth season saw the we
we're always trying to pull from certain
things from book six and other books in
the series we've always been sort of
free to kind of play around with some of
the chronology and take thing borrow
things from different books so we're not
you know perfect about a book a season
it will continue that going forward I
mean the over the large arc that's still
defining where we are is we're in the
new world were in the American colonies
and the American Revolution is getting
closer and closer so that's like a big
thing that's going to be moving from the
center and that the further that we get
into season six
if I'm not mistaken there's been talk
about an outlander spin-off what's the
status of that we're still talking about
it you know stars is interested and
we're definitely in conversations Sony
and stars are in conversations about
about a spin-off series yeah do you guys
is it one of these things where you're
still figuring out what that can be or
do you sort of have an idea but you're
not saying yeah we have we have we have
more than one idea we have a couple of
ideas and we're just you know we're
there's still an internal conversation
so we're not really prepared to go out
and say what it is